in just the past few years scientists
have been discovering the same building
blocks of life we have here on earth
elsewhere in the universe oxygen water
and methane all found on planets outside
of our solar system now something else
can be added to the mix the carbon
dioxide is the kind of the main focus of
the excitement because that is a
molecule that under the right
circumstances could have a connection to
biological activity as it does on earth
the key phrase there under the right
circumstances doesn't apply here the
planet marks Wayne and his team are
looking at is way too hot almost 5,000
degrees Fahrenheit still astronomers
believe the finding inches is closer to
the ultimate goal beautiful the very
fact that we're able to detect it and
met an estimate how much of it there is
is significant for the the long-term
effort of characterizing planets both to
find out what they're made of and to
find out if they could be a possible
host for life in order to study a
faraway atmosphere they can't even see
astronomers rely on studying the heat or
infrared radiation coming off of it
first they take a measurement when the
planet is right next to its parent star
then they check out the heat values when
the planet is behind the star subtract
and what's left over is the chemical
signature of the planet if you would
have asked me five years ago I would
have said that in 50 years from now we
probably would be able to detect
molecules in the atmospheres of these
planets and actually we're doing it
right now science is about learning and
discovering the laws of nature and these
laws are really are universal that you
know anywhere you go in the universe the
same laws apply laws that drive life
here on earth and maybe elsewhere for
the Space Telescope Science Institute in
Baltimore Maryland I'm Mary Astacio